hey devon good morning what's up man how
are you doing
doing well how about yourself yeah hey
uh just curious i guess your
your reaction to the off-season moves
that you guys made with chris and
and jay specifically and for you how is
the feeling different this year going in
now that
i guess people are there's a lot of
expectations and hype surrounding this
team which
you haven't really had for you know your
first few years in the league here
uh yeah i mean i'm trying to you know
stay at the same thought process and
stay motivated and stay with the same
tunnel vision but
you know it's obviously the obvious the
changes that we made and
you know the the depth that we have on
this team now
so you know obviously very excited
to get out there and start competing
with these guys
but as far as the expectations the hype
um the projections what people are
saying about us
you know it's still the same mentality
that we had in the bubble you know we're
focused on getting better
um and we don't really care you know
what people are saying you know we have
very talented people you know in this
group and we understand that
and now it's our job to you know get the
best out of this group and get the full
capability of
you know each player on this team
next up we have dwayne rankin with the
arizona republic he'll be followed by
richard science
hey palmer uh devon just to follow that
up
uh chris was on yesterday and talked
about you and him
uh having battles going back to you was
going into the draft and how intense
uh it got it gets when you guys play
against each other
knowing that and knowing about him
two-part question one
how intense does it get when you guys go
at it
and then two what do you feel like he
can bring
to the team in that regard um
i mean it gets very intense you know i
think he said yesterday
you know we about we'd be about to fight
sometimes but you know i think that's
just two competitors going at it
um and trying to win the game and you
know at the same time doing anything for
for your team to win um and if that's
not being
friends with your with your friends at
the time while you're in between the
lines and
you know those are the lines you have to
cross but you know
i mean he's an ultra competitor and he's
been for
for many long years that's why he has
the resume that he has
but his leadership you know even in his
short time here
just the camaraderie of bringing
everybody together and you know keeping
everybody aware and locked in
you know just his presence around the
team just makes you want to work that
much harder
um like i said knowing his wrestling
knowing the places that he's been
you know that we're all trying to go so
you know just just following this lead
but at the same time
you know adding adding our value
um and all helping each other out you
know with the main goal of
of trying to win every basketball game
we can
next up is richard science with fox 10
he'll be followed by kellen olsen
hey devon uh good to see you again it
seems like you know just yesterday
you guys were making that 8-0 run in the
disney bubble and the season
you know just ended so this is a i know
a quick turnaround
but considering the way you guys
finished you know in the bubble and the
moves you guys have made in the off
season are you kind of glad that it's
been a quick turnaround because you you
know kind of wanted to hurry up and get
back on the court and
finish you know kind of what you guys
started
yeah i love basketball so every time
it's
you know approaching that time where we
get the chance to
you know i i have competition on myself
and my workouts
every time i go out there we have
competition between teammates
and shooting drills and one-on-one
drills but
you know you can't you can't
recreate that feeling of planning into
other team and doing
you know everything in your power to win
um so i'm getting
i'm getting excited to get back to that
feeling and you know we definitely had
some
some great energy building throughout
the bubble you know great culture
farming and
you know with the additions of this team
that we have with there being a lot of
them
you know with some veteran guys some
some grown men that
you know know know their role and know
what they are in this nba
and you know have the same objective of
you know competing and winning games
rather than you know get getting better
and
you know trying to prove what you can do
you know i think we have a
really sound team of people that you
know know what they're capable of doing
and
you know figuring out how that meshes
together as a team is
you know our next objective
all right next up is kellen olsen with
arizona sports he'll be followed by
christos saltos
hey book good to see you uh so you got
to play with jamal two years ago and i
know you talked a lot about how that was
one of your idols growing up and
this year you get to play with chris who
i'm sure holds similar ground for you
what can you take from what you learned
from jamal two years ago that can kind
of go into chris now and like the
kind of like absorbing everything jamal
told you and what i'm sure chris will be
telling you this year too
uh those are two hall of fame guys you
know in my eyes
and being a student of this game for a
very long time
i told chris you know when i used to
visit my dad at mississippi sometimes i
watched him play in new orleans like
watch them play live
and to think i was i don't know the
exact age don't quote me but probably
14 15 years old um
and just being a fan of this game i
think people pulled up some old tweets
of
me being excited about getting invited
to you know his uh
his skills academy camp um pre-giraffe
he came and worked out with me d'angelo
and carl so
you know as many times in the past that
we've you know
crossed paths and obviously i knew who
he was a long time
before nba was you know even in my mind
but
you know just even even guys like jamal
and chris like you said just being
around them just soaking in
everything you can just being a sponge
to that you know hearing the stories
that they have
those things keep me motivated and you
know make me want to make my mark
and be able people to be able to tell
those same stories about
about myself you know as i continue and
keep going through the same
next up we have christo seltos with
sport dna in greece
he'll be followed by cody cunningham
hello
hello devin i would like to ask you uh
how excited you are about the next
season with
the moves that phoenix sans made and do
you believe that
this season your team is one of the
playoffs
team in west um
i'm excited you know that's that's what
we've been talking about a lot of time
on here um but we're not going to get
too ahead of ourself
of you know trying to live up to the
expectations that everybody has for us
you know i've never been that type of
guy um you know i have in-house goals we
have in-house goals as this team
um and for this culture so you know
we're going to stick by that
and that's and that's what we're going
to do worry about what we have to worry
about
and that's winning basketball games and
that's developing this team and
and figuring out you know that that it
is a short
turnaround you know how are we going to
get out in the court and and figure out
you know how we're going to get things
done and you know how we're going to
mesh together
next up is cody cunningham with sons.com
he'll be followed by kent sommers
hey devin uh every year you seem to
prove something new you know you proved
you could be that go-to score
you proved that you could be the face of
the franchise you proved that you could
be a legit play maker
now in year six what are you looking to
prove
and throughout these years what
motivates you
um just win basketball games you know
that's my main objective
you know like you said i've took i've
taken steps um
in many directions and you know the one
column that
you know i feel have to change the most
is the win loss um
and playing playoff basketball and
playing competitive basketball to the
point where
you know we're we're getting we're
getting where we want to go
um wherever that is to us but um
you know just it's just everyday grind
man you know i
i come in here every day and focus on
the same
thing and i keep saying it's to get wins
and whatever i have to do to do that so
you know any any talking i can do about
it isn't gonna
you know change that you know it's the
work that we're gonna put in the
communication and the leadership
you know that that we have right here in
this locker room where it's going to get
done at
next up we have kent summers with the
arizona republic he'll be followed by
tressa rusnak
yeah devin thanks for doing this
i know i know you don't want to you know
get too far ahead of yourselves but
what you guys were able to accomplish
this summer
and plus you know the additions of chris
and others but
where do you think the organization is
as a as a whole right now
compared to you know a year ago or two
years ago
um i mean i think that's for everybody
else to decide
um like i said obviously making
improvements and i feel like the culture
has
definitely changed even from the bubble
to now or
from the season to the bubble you know
over any amount of time you know you're
going to build and
nurture and grow and we've took
tremendous steps and i think with the
additions of
the players that we added you know we
have a
a deaf team with with a lot of iq
and guys that know how to play the game
so you know i think everybody in this
locker room is locked in
and our students are the game and love
the game and love the process so
overall when you know when you walk in
this gym every day you know it feels
like an environment that
you can get better in and you know we
already have some really good players in
here so
you know it's a fun environment to work
in um it's a loving environment
um it's a caring environment and coach
monte and his staff has
have came in here and implemented that
implemented that
into us and we've taken that and ran
with it and
you know it feels good but you know
we're still building
hi devon good morning good morning
thank you for your time i just wanted to
ask you um
chris mentioned kind of like you said
the stories your back history with each
other is there a memory or a time when
you guys were playing or just
something that sticks out with him in
particular that you could recall
uh so many i think he he told the story
the first
first time i actually got to get on the
court with him was that that pre-draft
time when it was me carl and d'angelo
and he had just lost in the playoffs
with the clippers and we were out in la
training and
you know he pulled up fresh off the
season um
and that meant a lot a lot for us for
you know a hall of fame guy all-star guy
to
you know come in the gym and work with
us us guys i haven't proven anything in
our careers yet
so you know it just shows you how much
he loves the game you know fresh off a
playoff loss to be out there
in the in the gym with some pre-draft
guys you know getting some good work in
um i remember after that after the
workout he invited us over to his house
you know started talking to us about off
the court things things we have to look
for
look forward to or look out for going
into the nba
so you know just his presence always you
know not only been basketball
and his resume can speak for itself but
you know the things that he does with
the players association and things that
he does for this league
and the leadership that he brings to all
of us you know is very big time
all right next up we have cheerston
souza with 12 news she'll be followed by
greg moore
hey devon sometimes when uh there's
someone that you look up to and they
think
very highly of you and obviously chris
paul is one of those guys
has nothing but amazing things to say
about you and your game and your work
ethic
does that motivate you to hear that kind
of stuff or know that he that he
now uh thinks that of you yeah that
drives me
you know you can feel it like i said
earlier you can feel this present in
presence in the gym and it's not you
know it's not necessarily
you're out there to impress him you know
you just know the
the level of play that he's played at
the level of intensity and the level of
competitive spirit that he's always
performed at
and you know i've never dealt with it
firsthand and being next to them but
just watching from afar
um you know so just taking that similar
approach and implementing
you know my own type of ways um
there's a lot of guys out here that you
know i respect
at a tremendous level but you know at
the same time i have to compete with
them but this time it's a little
different you know i have this guy
in the locker room you know saying when
we talk about the jamal
crawford you know a couple questions to
go you know these guys
are full with rich history and i love it
man these are places that i'm trying to
go and things i'm trying to do
you know so it definitely holds me to a
higher standard every time i walk in
here
all right devon next up is greg moore
with the arizona republic he'll be
followed by brendan clean
devin what's up man good to see you
what's up guys nothing too much dude
i was thinking about cam and mikhail and
dario
and them shooting after practice cam
said yesterday he's the best shooter
i want to know if you're going to get in
that i know how competitive you are are
you going to get in that competition to
show these guys what's up
what competition just three-point
shooting maybe after practice
man tom i got the three-point trophy man
so i'm first second and third once cam
gets over there we'll talk to him man
now i'm kidding cam has a stroke man you
watch it he's one of those guys that
you watch it come off his hands and
every time you think it's in
so it's perfect perfect release great
height on a great arc
and you see the improvements that he
made in the short amount of time just
from the season to the bubble
so he's coming into his own and yeah i
see him on the other end shooting it
looks good but
i wouldn't take it that far greg and
leaning on your your expertise man like
you being a student of the game and all
how important uh
are those you know role players
so-called role players so-called
supporting cast to the support of any
team with high aspirations
i mean i think you you just have to
understand it's a team sport at the end
of the day
um especially if you you know if you're
a fan of the game you watch the playoffs
and you watch the defenses that
you know are tailored to these you know
to these
high-powered offenses you know everybody
has to be able to play the game
everybody has to be able to shoot
everybody has to be able to pass
you know so it's just the versatility
you know of knowing how to play and not
necessarily
going out there and running this play
running that play so
it's a read and react game
you know and i think i think our team
has that um
so the versatility read and react um
just just keep keep getting better for
us
i got away from that i forgot what the
question was
no actually actually you're good man i
was just thinking about just how
important uh are those kinds of guys uh
you know everybody's gonna put a lot of
pressure on you
and chris and deandre we know that but i
get the feeling that the other guys are
going to impress
everybody right team everybody so
you know we have options out there and
like i said it's just a read and react
game so
people are double teaming i get off i
make the right play and
you know you have very talented players
i wouldn't even say
role players what you guys call role
players out there
you know very talented guys that can
make teams pay for
any type of joint defense that they do i
agree with you we need a new name for
that thanks devin
for sure all right next up we have
brendan clean with bright side of the
sun he'll be followed by dwayne rankin
hey devon uh jay crowder came on the
radio
here this week and said that that you
had reached out to him
when he was making his decision he had
other offers maybe more money
a different role different places but
that that conversation was helpful to
him but then even on the other side of
it that
seeing what you guys did in the bubble
made him feel like
this was a place he could come and win
and that's not necessarily what
guys would have said in the past and so
i'm curious from you what
stood out about jay that you thought
would be a good situation here
and and be just kind of what it means to
hear from a guy like that who's done so
much winning
that he feels like this is a place he
can keep doing that
yeah man that says a lot you know i
think that was what was most
important you know for this organization
and this team this summer is
one having guys wanting to come here um
a guy like jay wanted to come here
guy like chris a hall of fame guy
wanting to come to phoenix after what
we've been through
you know for the past five to ten years
um you know so i think that's a step
forward for you know for this
organization and people really see
something's brewing over here you know
i'm not i'm trying to not get ahead of
myself but
you know i think already this is a big
step for this organization um
and it's perfect time man we have the
the new arena new practice facility that
we're in now
um so it's a great culture around here
um and it's still building you know
that's what we're working on every day
is keep building the culture keep making
this
you know this facility this locker room
a place that guys want to come and keep
getting better
you know because this is fun for us you
know we're having fun in here
you know the energy's high the
personality's out
um and the competitiveness is there you
know we can joke all we want walking in
in the locker room but once we touch the
weight room and touch the court it's all
about business
with this group and i've just noticed
that in the in the short time here so
you know the culture's rising um and
those staples those guys that you know
are wanting to come out here and join
this team
you know has has been a big plus for us
next up we have dwayne rankin with the
arizona republic he'll be followed by
brittany hardy
uh yes devon a two-parter one
uh obviously you knowing chris and
having played with deandre
how do you see that that marriage
working obviously chris
has a always has a connection with with
the bigs in terms of lobs and and just
playing pick and roll
and then two just the new practice
facility what do you think of it
is it what you expected or even more
yeah the racist between chris's deandre
is going to be great man
you know i've already pulled deandre
aside a couple of times to be like
this is what you needed and this is what
i needed also
um and that's that's saying nothing to
any player we've dealt with in the past
but chris you know he he's a guy that he
expects greatness
you know out of us he expects to win um
and he wants to win
very badly and i'm on the same page as
him
you know so i know he's going to do and
say anything and hold people accountable
at all times
you know to to reach that goal that
we're trying to make and
you know we already have the
understanding amongst all of us that
you know we have the same goals and
where we want to go
so there's going to be a lot of
constructive criticism around here
which is what we need i feel like that's
how you build cultures being honest with
each other and
you know holding each other accountable
so you know hopefully we can create an
environment where
you know we can we can all learn from
christian that way um of being vocal and
you know letting people know where they
need to be um and competing with people
and doing it with love doing it with
care not doing it with
you know intentions of showing somebody
that they messed up but intentionally
to really get better and learn and not
make the same mistakes again and
you know that's going to be good for me
and deandre
up we have brittany hardy with nba tv
she'll be followed by paul richardson
hi devin um the pandemic changed the way
we watch sports what is it about the
game that keeps you engaged keeps you
motivated as a player during these
unprecedented times
and what about the game draws and fans
you said what about the game that keeps
me driven
i said what about the game that keeps
you engaged and motivated during these
times yes
um i just love it you know and i and i
want to be the best at it and i
and i haven't lost sight of that um and
i want to win basketball games
i want to win a championship i want to
do a lot of things um so there's
there's a lot to still be motivated
motivated about
um obviously with so much going on
you know it's kind of escape you know
when we go into our bubble when we go
into a facility
and are tested every day you know it's a
sense of security where
you know you can you can let it down and
just get better
um you know so we still have goals um
and it's changing the way people view it
but for for a hooper and for me
you know it still feels the same you
know people are asking about what's the
environment like in the bubble
um and you heard multiple people say
you know it's a hooper's environment
it's just strictly basketball
and it's easy to focus into like that
with
with no distractions and a whole lot of
extra things going on
next up we have paul richardson with the
sports cave he'll be followed by kellen
olsen
hey devon how you doing my man so
everyone talks about offense offense
offense but coach the other day said
that you're also an incredible
competitor on the defensive end
and you're like to guard your position
what is it going to be
like now bringing in jay who is you know
a doggy defender along with chris and
the attitude
and the mental toughness that's going to
be on that end of the court
to complement what you guys already do
offensively yeah
i mean i guess we'll see um we
definitely have some dogs man we have
some go-getters
um we have a lot of people that i feel
like
they don't want their match-up to score
and they don't want their teammates
match up to score so
you know basketball you know it's
contagious on the offense and defense
and with communication
you know i think team defenses
is um it's how you can improve people's
individual defense to helping each other
out and talking and
being there early and rotating early and
knowing if you rotate that your teammate
has your back
and i think with a bunch of guys that
you know understand the game
and have a high iq for the game mixed
with that
mix with that dog that that intensity
where
you don't want your man to score is
going to be a good mix on that defense
and so
you know i can see i could see a lot of
little in team competition
of somebody saying don't let their man
score at some time
at this on this team um and i could see
people switching matchups you know
whoever
i think we have a versatile group where
you know if
me and jay and michelle are all up on
the wings guarding wings two through
four that we could we could switch
same with cam same with everybody on
this team so the versatility and the
communication is where it's going to be
key
all right devin final two questions
we've got kellen olsen with arizona
sports and he'll be followed by jace
frederick
hey book i know won't surprise you that
a lot of people's first thoughts when
jay was announced was the the 70 uh the
night of and you guys just having a
little fun banter were you guys able to
laugh about that in a couple
conversations you've had and uh
i know every everyone's like making a
big deal out of it but obviously like
that's just some friendly stuff and you
guys are competitors at the end of the
day
yeah for sure this has happened multiple
times in my career
with troy daniels at one point um and
now jay but
people have to understand man especially
with me
um the trash talking has always been
part of my game you know
having fun with the the competition has
always been part
of the game but you know nothing's ever
stretched past
you know farther than the court you know
for me um
and jay's the same way and we were
talking about it earlier just guys that
that want to compete and love to compete
at that highest level
you know obviously it's going to get
emotional obviously you don't like to
lose obviously
like i said you don't want your man to
score on you and those are the type of
guys that you want to be around
also that's how you create that energy
that aura
um in that field um
and you know we've talked many times
after that we haven't even brought that
up
so that's not even something that we we
would even
even speak about i'm sure at some point
of the season we'll laugh about it but
you know that was just good friendly
social media banter
all right devin final question is going
to come from jace frederick with pioneer
press
hey devon tim rules reporter hopping on
from minnesota um ricky rubio i just
want to know
playing with him last year how did he
help your game and do you maybe make
your game as an elite scorer a little
easier at times and uh do you think you
can have a similar impact with deangelo
this year
easier at times easier at all times um
you know i talked to ricky you know
after after the trade happened you know
i just thanked him
um for being a part of that you know of
coming in here and and changing that
culture and
you know showing what an nba team and
and having a
a leader around that's going to come in
here and work hard every day and
and try to compete um and i've told
d'angelo he's going to love him already
um and i'm happy he's in a good place
back in minnesota
but i'll never forget what he's done for
my career um
one game shot of the playoffs that's one
thing that we talked about that was one
of our goals that
you know we almost got to he also told
me he was
happy he could be a part of my first
all-star and and helped me reach
that so you know a lot of love for ricky
rubio and
his career and you know his short time
spent in phoenix would never be
forgotten in my eyes
all right appreciate the time devin